going to jump right in on this historic
day the word unprecedented has been used
in connection with former president
Donald Trump many times over the last
eight years when supporters of the
president stormed the capital to disrupt
the Democratic process we called it
unprecedented when then president Trump
was impeached for a second time in the
Twilight of his presidency that was also
unprecedented and today once again we
are witnessing something else
unprecedented former president Donald
Trump is expected to turn himself in to
face criminal charges in a New York City
courtroom in the history of this country
this has never happened before we have
multiple people covering this today
including Jeff pagayas at Trump Tower
and Robert Costa outside the courthouse
in lower Manhattan and that is where we
start Bob good morning
good morning Nate former president Trump
will be here at this Courthouse later
today a judge ruled overnight that no
video will be permitted in the courtroom
but some still photos will be allowed
this comes after the Trump lawyers
argued that cameras could create a quote
circus-like atmosphere
thank you
former president Donald Trump emerged
from his Mar-A-Lago estate Monday to the
cheers of supporters lining the streets
as he began his journey to face an
expected arraignment today we just want
to keep his morale up he's a strong man
strongest man I've known
and he's taken a lot of heat
Trump boarded his private plane in West
Palm Beach Florida bound for an
unprecedented New York homecoming he
touched down at LaGuardia Airport and
went straight to Trump Tower where
security has been on high alert amid
this historic moment a former president
being criminally indicted days after he
called on his supporters to protest
President Biden weighed in for the first
time Monday
so
around midday today Trump is set to
leave Trump Tower and head to the
criminal court in lower Manhattan to
surrender Trump would be fingerprinted
then he's set to be arraigned at 2 15
p.m the indictment remains sealed but
sources say Trump will likely be charged
with falsifying business records in the
first degree which is a felony this is
in connection to the money allegedly
used to silence porn star Stormy Daniels
during his 2016 presidential run unless
I've completely misread the universe uh
you should not expect a guilty please
attorney Jim trustee represents Trump in
two separate Federal cases he says he
expects the Trump team to push to have
the case dismissed I think that a lot of
people a lot of legal Scholars and folks
like myself are in agreement that there
could be some very significant motions
filed in short order I mean within days
or weeks not weeks or months Trump
bolstered his legal team Monday by
bringing on veteran criminal defense
lawyer Todd Blanche after Tuesday's
Court proceedings Trump is expected to
return to Florida where he is set to
deliver remarks in a ball
this evening
district attorney Alvin Bragg who has
been relentlessly criticized by Trump
will also speak out today holding a news
conference after the arraignment Nate
Bob thank you we'll check in with you
later